Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
"Voi vi fidate ancora dei media"?
Per anni ho posto questa domanda.
Prima di tutto a me stesso,
e poi a decine, anzi centinaia di persone.
Queste persone erano i lettori,
i lettori degli articoli che scrivevo
o i lettori dei giornali
per cui ho lavorato.
Forse non vi stupirà,
ma in molti casi la risposta
è stata un secco: “No, non mi fido”.
O ancora peggio: “No, non mi fido più”.
Lavoro nei media da oltre 15 anni:
ho iniziato scrivendo
per qualche giornale locale,
poi ho scritto per siti
di politica, sport, tecnologia;
e oggi progetto strategie digitali
per testate nazionali e internazionali.
E in questi 15 anni,
ho visto il mondo crollare
sotto ai miei piedi.
Ho visto i lettori perdere sempre di più
la fiducia nei media e nel giornalismo.
Ma che cosa è successo?
Per spiegarvelo,
questa sera voglio partire
da una frase leggendaria: questa.
“All the news that’s fit to print”:
tutte le notizie
che vale la pena stampare.
Questa frase è leggendaria,
e te la insegnano quando inizi
a studiare giornalismo.
E te la insegnano perché è il motto
del giornale più famoso al mondo.
Campeggia sotto la sua testata dal 1897
e da allora, in quasi 125 anni,
non è mai cambiata.
Ma chi è che decideva
che cosa è “fit to print”,
che cosa vale la pena stampare?
Be’, i giornalisti.
I giornalisti,
che avevano l'onere e il privilegio
di scegliere e filtrare i fatti,
e decidere che cosa
diventasse notiziabile.
Che avevano un contenitore, il giornale,
e ne sceglievano
tutti i giorni il contenuto.
Per oltre un secolo,
i giornali sono stati visti
come delle istituzioni:
quasi intoccabili,
della cui oggettività,
della cui credibilità,
ci dovevamo fidare ciecamente.
Poi, però, è successo qualcosa.
E che cosa?
È arrivato Internet, con la sua fluidità,
e i punti di accesso alle notizie
sono diventati, improvvisamente,
molti, molti di più.
Se prima c'erano poche fonti,
ed erano fonti di cui,
tendenzialmente, ci fidavamo
perché erano validate
dalla nostra rete sociale,
per esempio dalla nostra famiglia,
oppure dai nostri amici,
oggi queste fonti si sono
moltiplicate esponenzialmente,
e viaggiano su tanti canali diversi,
su tanti device diversi.
Viaggiano tutte le ore
del giorno e della notte;
e soprattutto, viaggiano
a grandissima velocità.
Io non credo, come dice qualcuno,
che non ci sia più così tanto
giornalismo di qualità, oggi:
anzi, io sono convinto del contrario.
Io penso che non ci sia mai stato
così tanto giornalismo
di qualità come oggi.
Però la verità è che qualcosa è cambiato,
e il problema è che abbiamo perso
i nostri punti di riferimento.
In questo sovraccarico di informazioni
che ci colpisce costantemente sui social,
sulle app, sui telefoni, sui computer,
diventa sempre più difficile capire
che cosa è real e che cosa è fake,
distinguere informazione
e disinformazione.
Ed è diventato sempre più difficile
rispondere a questa domanda:
“Chi è che decide cosa è 'Fit to print',
che cosa vale la pena stampare oggi? ”.
In questa marea di informazioni,
abbiamo ancora gli anticorpi
per fare la scelta giusta?
Meno credibilità, meno fiducia,
hanno portato anche a meno copie vendute,
meno pubblicità, meno abbonati.
E questa crisi, che potremmo
definire psicologica,
è diventata anche, e soprattutto,
una crisi economica
che ha mietuto vittime, piccole e grandi,
a livello locale, a livello nazionale
e anche a livello internazionale.
Io, però, credo che questa crisi
non sia irreversibile;
anzi, credo che ci sia una soluzione.
E la soluzione è costruire
un nuovo modello di business
basato sulla fiducia,
appoggiandosi su un concetto
nuovo e potente:
quello dell'”economia della relazione”.
Per spiegarvi che cos'è
l'economia della relazione, stasera,
voglio fare un salto indietro nel tempo,
alla primavera del 2012.
In quel periodo mi ero
appena trasferito a Berlino,
e avevo cofondato
un giornale online, “Il Mitte”.
“Il Mitte” si rivolgeva alla community
degli italiani a Berlino,
gli forniva notizie, consigli,
spunti su come organizzare la loro vita
nella capitale tedesca.
Siccome avevamo lanciato
da poche settimane,
ci sembrò una buona idea quella di fare
un piccolo evento, un aperitivo:
quindi scegliamo un bar,
pubblichiamo un annuncio su Facebook.
E quella sera, quell'evento,
è il momento esatto
in cui io ho capito per la prima volta
che cos'è l'economia della relazione:
in questo momento qui.
Quello di spalle sono io,
e questa per me è una foto di Internet.
No non è una foto di Internet
intesa come infrastruttura di Internet:
non ci sono cavi, non ci sono antenne,
non ci sono schermi, non ci sono router.
Però, per me, questa è proprio una foto
di Internet e del suo potere.
Quella sera ci saremmo aspettati
che qualcuno sarebbe passato,
incuriosito dal progetto;
ma mi ricordo che quella sera contammo,
e incontrammo, 99 persone.
E chi erano, queste 99 persone?
Be’, ovviamente erano italiani;
altrettanto ovviamente,
vivevano a Berlino,
alcuni da poche settimane
o da qualche mese,
altri invece erano lì già da qualche anno.
E che cosa cercavano,
perché erano venute quella sera?
Cercavano, lo capii, una relazione,
intesa come un modo
per scambiarsi informazioni
su come registrarsi all'anagrafe,
come imparare il tedesco,
come sottoscrivere
un'assicurazione sanitaria;
ma anche su cosa fare il weekend.
Erano persone con background diversi,
con interessi diversi:
ma erano accomunati da simili bisogni,
simili necessità
e anche da simili domande.
Mi ricordo che,
a un certo punto della serata,
giravo un po’ tra i tavolini,
origliavo le conversazioni
tra piccoli gruppi di persone
che fino a mezz'ora, un'ora prima,
non si conoscevano:
“Senti, ma come si vive
in quel quartiere?”
“Hai letto quella notizia?”
“Perché non andiamo
insieme a quell'evento?”
E queste conversazioni poggiavano
su dei bit, delle unità di informazione
che erano state veicolate
dal Mitte, il mio giornale.
E fu in quel momento che capii
che se il giornale era un contenitore,
non era un contenitore solamente
di notizie, di articoli, di contenuti.
Era un contenitore di relazioni.
Era una piattaforma attraverso la quale
la community degli italiani a Berlino,
nei mesi e negli anni successivi,
si sarebbe conosciuta,
si sarebbe connessa,
sarebbe diventata più stretta,
più salda, più cosciente di sé
e anche in grado di aiutarsi
in caso di bisogno.
È proprio questa connessione personale,
digitale e anche economica
che fa la differenza, oggi,
nei media digitali.
Questa economia della relazione, per me,
poggia su tre valori fondamentali.
Il primo è l'ascolto,
la capacità di comprendere
i bisogni dei lettori.
La seconda è il dialogo,
la capacità di aprirsi, anche con umiltà,
alle idee, ai feedback,
e alle critiche dei lettori.
E la terza, forse la più importante,
è l'empatia:
la capacità di identificarsi
con i lettori, di assomigliargli,
ma anche di crescere
e di cambiare con loro.
Come forse avrete visto dalle foto,
da quella sera a Berlino
sono passati un po’ di anni:
però il mio viaggio di scoperta
all'interno dell'economia della relazione
è ben lontano dal terminare.
Oggi vedo diversi media
in grado di parlare “al” proprio pubblico;
ma ne vedo ancora
veramente, veramente pochi
in grado di dialogare
“con” il proprio pubblico.
Il giornalismo oggi, per sopravvivere,
non può più essere un dittatore,
e non può più nemmeno essere un dettatore.
Non può dirci che cosa dobbiamo sapere,
non può imporci una verità
e non può più nemmeno pensare
di essere abbastanza:
dev'essere, piuttosto, un facilitatore
in grado di formare connessioni di valore,
e anche di agevolare
uno scambio orizzontale di informazioni
all'interno di una community.
Perché questo avvenga, però, c'è bisogno
della collaborazione di tutti:
dei giornali, dei giornalisti,
ma anche di voi, anche dei lettori.
Se pensate che il giornalismo
abbia ancora un valore per la società,
o magari addirittura
un valore per la democrazia,
allora apritevi, dialogate,
esigete di più dai giornali, criticateli.
E se trovate qualcuno,
o qualcosa, che vi soddisfa,
sostenetelo, anche economicamente.
Tornate a dirci -
in un modo o nell'altro,
non importa quale -
queste tre parole: “Io mi fido”.
Perché al centro
dell'economia della relazione
ci siamo noi, le persone.
E sapete qual è la cosa bella?
Che l'economia della relazione
non vale soltanto per me,
non vale solamente per i giornali;
ma si applica a ciascuno di voi,
nelle vostre carriere professionali
e anche nelle vostre sfere personali.
Se domani mattina qualcuno
bussasse alla mia porta,
e mi dicesse “Valerio,
perché non fondi un nuovo giornale?”,
io non credo che sotto la mia testata
vorrei che fosse scritto
“All the news that’s fit to print”,
tutte le notizie
che vale la pena stampare.
Vorrei, piuttosto,
che il mio motto fosse un altro:
“All the relationships
that’s fit to build”,
tutte le relazioni
che vale la pena costruire.
Per i giornali, per i giornalisti,
ma anche e soprattutto per i lettori.
Perché, come imparai quella sera a Berlino
nella primavera del 2012,
davanti a quelle 99 persone,
nella migliore lezione di giornalismo
che io abbia mai frequentato,
la fiducia si ricostruisce soltanto così:
attraverso l’ascolto,
attraverso il dialogo
e attraverso l'empatia.